hannity it's great to see you in
teachers as always all right i'm laura
ingram this is the ingram angle from new
york city tonight tipping over and
falling down that's the focus of
tonight's angle
now we can start the show the easy way
tonight on biden's dismount skills or we
could just focus on that weird whisper
thing he did today on the beach
i'm also very proud of some of the
states like right here in delaware
and passing assault weapons
why does he do that or we could just
poke fun of the least fun person on the
face of the planet
liz cheney
had the vice president of the united
states obeyed the president of the
united states
america would immediately have been
plunged into what would have been
tantamount to a revolution within a
paralyzing constitutional crisis
but instead let's talk about what
matters shall we it's called the future
now here's the bottom line the western
establishment is losing its ability to
govern completely
what happened in the french
parliamentary elections over the weekend
was absolutely stunning and americans
should pay attention to this the pretty
boy liberal emmanuel macron lost a
governing majority driven by huge gains
by the right and left-wing parties
now for years there's been an
undercurrent of discontent building
throughout europe as working people were
falling further behind
this was preceded by the islamic refugee
influx and now of course inflationary
concerns and the ukraine russia
nightmare
so rather than address the needs of
their people
the old european guard seems obsessed
with living out their fantasies of the
new global order you know what i'm
talking about taming capitalism
punishing wealth creators
and of course biden's totally on board
with that we also can move in a
direction that we can provide for
the tax increasing tax taxes on those
in the
corporate area as well as
individuals as it relates to uh trump's
tax cuts
how original higher taxes i haven't
heard that before
political elites are just no longer
nimble because even when they bring in a
charismatic newcomer and obviously
that's not biden someone like an obama
or david cameron or emmanuel macron
it doesn't work because those folks are
trapped in the same old cycle of tax
spend and divide
oh and the gerontocracy they've been out
of steam for many years everything they
did since biden got in has made things
worse
we had to ratchet up spending we put
money in the economy we tried to keep
businesses open try to keep people with
income in their pockets and whenever you
do that you run the risk of inflating
things
and what you then have to do
is try to find uh some balance in all of
that and we're searching for that
balance we'll get there
the balance well the voters are already
there they see what the balance is
congressman and they're out of patience
so the time has come to recognize that
history has entered a new chapter the
old solutions that might have worked to
some extent maybe back in the 90s they
don't even make sense today
here in the united states we have to
forget talking about a new republican
majority to quote newt gingrich our next
guest
we need a new american majority new
coalitions
and the following reforms have to take
place
number one we have to promote fair
economic growth
we need an economy that features overall
growth and higher wages for working
people so basically the same type of
economy we had before covet hit
this means we need to get americans back
to work physically back to work with tax
and regulatory policies that encourage
and reward going to work
but we also need trade and immigration
policies that are going to prevent
plutocrats from just outsourcing jobs or
preventing working americans from making
their fair share let's use their lingo
number two we need a realistic game plan
to deal with the rise of china we don't
have that now
the current establishment is simply too
weak and too compromised to ever meet
the challenge presented by the ccp
and as things stand currently
i hate to say it this bluntly but we are
on pace to lose our independence and
eventually become a puppet state of the
ccp
so we need a complete reform of our
military our intelligence community our
diplomats
no one and i mean
no one
thinks china fears this man
we cannot wait
for the rest of the world either no one
by the way is calling for isolationism
they always like hit you back with that
one it's simply an absurd lie but we
cannot wait for countries like france
germany and japan to help us
to be candid the rest of the world
thinks that america is in terminal
decline at this point and that the
future probably belongs to china
so no one's going to make sacrifices to
help us if they think we're doomed
number four we need a patriotic
government
too many people in dc and i've been
there for too long i'm sorry to admit
they're simply serving time until they
can go lobby for multinational
corporations or yes even for the chinese
too many washington bureaucrats are
taking taxpayer dough to sit at home
instead of doing
the normal thing like go to work go to
the office
too many of our diplomats are more
concerned about the world than defending
our national interests we're looking at
the largest economic opportunity and
transformation since the industrial
revolution and this will be bigger
because every nation in the world is
going to have to move to a clean new
energy economy and future of course
that's music to china's ears
america is unilaterally disarming in the
energy battle right now while china is
burning coal building coal plants using
oil
undeterred by kerry's green diplomacy
they're just laughing
meanwhile as all this is happening the
pentagon is more concerned about being
woke than about preparing to kill our
enemies check out this pride month
pronoun training video now being used by
the us navy
hi my name is johnny and i use he him
pronouns hi and i'm kanji and i use chi
her pronouns and we're here to talk
about pronouns using the right pronouns
is a really simple way to affirm
someone's identity it is a signal of
acceptance and respect if it's a signal
of acceptance and respect how do we go
about creating a safe space for
everybody
okay my lord this is embarrassing this
this has no place in our military or
anywhere frankly it's just stupid
the democrats do believe they have an
answer however to this perceived
patriotism deficit it comes in the form
of something called a new civics secures
democracy act it's a mouthful it's just
reintroduced in congress
well stanley kurtz tells us that if it's
passed it will allow the biden
administration to push critical race
theory on every public school in america
over a six-year period a six billion
dollar pot of competitive grant money
will create a de facto national
curriculum
csda has added republican senators bill
cassidy from louisiana and jim inhofe
from oklahoma as co-sponsors sponsors of
the newly reintroduced bill
unless america's parents wake up and
make themselves heard now there's a very
real chance that crt could be the new
common core by summer
now this is insane
but except for these foolish republicans
giving him cover it's not really
surprising more on this in just a few
moments with newt gingrich
for years the left has spread
anti-american poison through our schools
our universities of course the media
movies corporate boards every other
forum
so we need new leaders who are proud of
america and who work every day to defend
her interests
number five
we have to make america safe for social
conservatives
now in a desperate desperate effort to
hold on to power the current
establishment has alight itself with
radicals on the left who just want to
ban social conservatives including
devout christians muslims and orthodox
jews from the public square period
because in today's democrat party and in
much of corporate america you just can't
participate at the highest levels if you
have the wrong religious beliefs
heck you can't even coach a high school
football team
and i thought that somebody of any kind
of faith would have to hide who they are
or you know have to
you know
just be ashamed of of them being you
know a
you know anybody of faith that's just
wrong in my book
this is not only wrong it also means
that we're not giving all of our best
and brightest people a chance to fully
participate in civic life
so these attitudes aren't just poisoning
the democratic party they've infected
many state and city governments
and they're in common with the media in
our top colleges and even in the
military so this has to stop
but we do know how to fix all these
problems don't we
because if you look at where the u.s
economy was back in 2019 or
where florida and texas are today
the policies that would fix most of this
those
work were tried are being used
so the decline of america is not
inevitable
a new survey by yougov yahoo tonight
indicates that americans are disgusted
with joe biden's performance
and even with liz and benny's january 6
mudslinging they prefer trump now in a
head-to-head matchup
wow
so americans know a failed establishment
when they see it in its handling of
covid afghanistan false promises on
ukraine prices at the pump at the
grocery store the crime surge
thousands of flights being canceled over
the holiday weekend that was fun
so biden tipping over on his bike
yeah that's bad
but america tipping into third world
status
that is unacceptable
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else